Ramfis Myrthil, Film Producer, Film
Consultant and Speaker: Sometimes you
work on a production and after you're
done you just don't want to produce
anymore you know and that's
how I felt after this I said…
Film Courage: Let's say you're on day four or
five of production long hours maybe there's been
issues with location and there's someone that
you deal with or different individuals on set
whose communication skills are maybe different
maybe they're more closed off maybe their arms
are crossed every time you go talk to them and
you can kind of pick up that there's like this
barrier especially later on in the production
how do you smoothly do that or is it at some
point it's just going to get tense there's
there you people are going to be human and
arguments will happen um I had this situation
happen maybe multiple times I'm thinking of
one specific situation that was very rough you
know for me I was coming off of a feature and
then I was jumping into a short that was very
aggressive and we had high level talent and
um my producing partner you know looked great on
paper but he'd never ran a film set and the line
producer that initially came on ended up just
walking and I don't think it was frustration or
anything because of us or the director but he
probably found a job that paid him a lot more
um and he didn't want to do all the
work I think that's the honest truth
um so in this project I brought on a a friend
colleague of mine that's kind of a producer
I asked her to come on as production manager
and um I want to say I don't remember if she
didn't come at all that day or maybe she
came and just never came back to set again
um but with this production it was a big
production we started in Central Park and
I had a financier that was coming that had put
on quite a bit of money into the project and he
wanted to come in take pictures on set he came
with his Entourage and at the same time I had
Talent checking in at a hotel nearby wanted
to make sure that he was okay and the other
Talent was okay and at the same time that day
the 59th Street Bridge I think was shut down uh
so our doctor photography was running late with
the camera and our sound person didn't come no
call no show and I have to be three places at one
time I have to be on set with my crew I have to
be with the talent to make sure they're okay and I
have to be with the financier and the A.D couldn't
really run the set and not that he couldn't run
the set but they were not listening to him and
the reason that we got the crew that we got which
was amazing like ayatsi crew was because of the DP
um our g e department and our camera department
and um this was day one everything went wrong
um I needed to get a sound person so I found
someone that had submitted from before and they
wanted double the rate and at this point we were
already spending money so I had to bring on this
person and it was very difficult to manage all the
expectations I felt that I was failing my team you
know all aspects in terms of the financier wanting
to be in and out and take pictures and telling him
hey we're trying to get cameras rolling that's not
important now but I know you put this money in so
I know you need to be here and you need you have
somewhere to go and you have all these people with
you um she was speaking with him um and his people
in a manner where they felt respected and not
disrespected and trying to manage the crew that
is like what the hell is going on why are these
people here and we just want to work um and then
the talent expecting a level of treatment per se
um and as the day went it just got harder and
harder there wasn't a smart plan for the gas
to get in the generator and we fell behind
schedule uh and I probably lost a few crew
members by the end of the night uh and
it was just very horrific I know the g
e team was really frustrated they thought
I didn't know probably what I was doing
um and they did not listen to the A.D they
only listened to the DP um and the second day
um I promised that it would be a much better day
we had some problems on the first day with meals
and the food getting there on time and it was just
a lot of Dynamics happening at the same time so I
did get everyone fed they did get fed a little
later um and uh I focused on the food that they
just to make sure that the food was really good uh
top of the line and there was an issue I want to
say with one of our main actresses because she was
playing the mother to this child and one of the
places I set up for holding happened to be a bar
near set and they would not allow the young boy in
um and that didn't even go through my mind it
would be a problem and she was having emotional
disconnect because that's her sons he was in
character and she would not do anything unless I
was there and I was focusing on making sort of you
know getting the food and working with the caterer
just to make sure that the food was slamming that
day and um I basically had to run and get over
there and you know I worked it out and you know
then she was okay and everything was all right
um and I could just feel the energy
from the genie crew and the camera crew
um it was more probably the g e crew that was more
upset um and I pretty much had to do something
about it because they were I felt that I was going
to lose all of them um or it was just going to get
worse so I asked the genie team to stop working
and to come out and speak with me they didn't know
what it was about and I had addressed everything
that happened the day before I had explained to
them which they knew about the camera and the
bridge you know I explained to them about the
sound I explained to them about the investor and
that they had put a good chunk of money in I had
this responsibility and you they probably didn't
care and I acknowledged that you probably I was
very honest and blunt you guys probably don't
care you just when you do your job I understand
I understand that you all ate late yesterday and
there was uh the gas was put in really late for
the generator and we've been behind schedule
I acknowledged everything that went wrong I
didn't ignore the pink elephant in the room I
acknowledged all of their concerns I let them
know all the Dynamics I was facing yesterday and
basically I'm producing this whole shoot on my own
and I literally wrapped on a feature right
before and I haven't had a chance to take a
break and again you guys probably don't care you
just want to do your job get fed and get paid
um and I acknowledge that I will treat them all
with respect I will make sure that they get fed
on time today and that I pretty much did not
go to sleep maybe an hour or two but I didn't
go to sleep to make sure that I have you know
better food for them because I had some people
that were vegetarian and vegan and all these
different things and um food was delayed the
day before so I made sure that wouldn't happen
and I felt that I had to have that conversation
because they were only there because of the DP
you know and I didn't want them to walk or lose
my team in the project fall apart because of
that um and it was it wasn't even a question I
knew I had to have this conversation or they would
probably start maybe disrespecting me or the set
or not listen because they weren't listening to
the first ad you know when I wasn't there there
um so I wanted to establish like a level of
authority as well and keep it and not lose it and
also let them know that they are humans I get that
and I'm not looking to be disrespectful to them or
the project at all um so I feel that that's what I
would do in any situation if it happened again is
just acknowledging what they or whatever person is
going through I'm not ignoring the problem letting
them know that I'm aware whether I can fix it or
not you know because a lot of times people want
to be heard um and I want to make sure that they
know that I'm listening and I I do care you know
whether I can make a decision or not sometimes
I can't make a decision you know I don't have
the authority to or it's a force outside of
nature in terms of what can or cannot be done
wow it sounds like I mean almost everything that
could have gone wrong did everything went wrong
on that project it was sometimes you work on
a production and after you're done you just
don't want to produce anymore you know and
that's how I felt after this I said I don't
want to be on a film set for a very long time I
can't manage this you know it was very stressful
um to the point where you know I lost my drivers
and I had box trucks that had to move around with
a lot of gear and equipment and I had bonded lots
that they had to get to and I lost all my drivers
and I had to call one of the PA's fathers really
stepped up he's a reverend he's a God-fearing man
and I think it's because you're religious it's
like why he helped and you know also his son
was a PA probably but he was like my savior
he drove the other box truck and didn't mind
and I had to drive the box truck you know I
don't drive box trucks I don't like driving
box trucks but if I didn't do it no one else
was and we had to get this film done you know
there were a lot of people counting on it getting
done and there was a lot at stake had to deliver.